CHRISTINE BREINER: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video, I'd like us to
work on the following problem.
So the problem is as follows.
For which of the
following vector fields
is the domain where
each vector field
is defined and
continuously differentiable
a simply connected region.
So there's a lot there.
I'm going to break that
down first, and then
show you the vector fields.
So we're starting with some
different vector fields.
And we want to determine first
the domain for each vector
field where it is both
defined and continuously
differentiable.
And then once you've
determined that domain,
the next object is to determine
whether or not that region is
simply connected.
So there are two parts for
each of these problems.
So again, the first
thing is you want
to determine all of the values
for which the vector field is
both defined and
continuously differentiable.
You want to look at that region
that contains all those values,
and you want to determine
if that region is simply
connected.
So there are four
different vector fields,
and I'll just point
them out here.
They're all in the plane.
So the first one is
root x i plus root y j.
The second one is i plus j,
divided by the square root of 1
minus x squared minus y squared.
The third one looks fairly
similar to the second one,
but it's i plus j,
divided by the square root
of the quantity x squared
plus y squared minus 1.
And the fourth one is i plus j
times the quantity natural log
of r squared-- natural log
of x squared plus y squared.
So there are four different
vector fields here.
You have do two
things for each one.
So find the domain where
it's defined and continuously
differentiable,
and then determine
if that domain is
simply connected.
So why don't you pause
the video, work on these,
and then when you're
ready to see what I did,
you can bring the video back up.
OK, welcome back.
So we're going to do
this problem one vector
field at a time.
We're going to take
each vector field,
I'm going to determine
where it's defined
and differentiable,
and then I'm going
to determine if that
region is simply connected.
So we're going to do
each one separately.
So I'm going to start
off with a, which
was root x i plus root y j.
And I want to point out
first, for the function
f of x is equal to square root
of x, it is defined for all x
greater than or equal to 0,
and it is differentiable for x
greater than 0.
I left out the T. There we go.
So it is both defined
and differentiable
when x is greater than 0.
And now if I replace
this with a y,
the same thing is true for y
greater than or equal to 0,
and y greater than 0.
So we know the region
where this vector field is
both defined and differentiable
is when x is greater
than 0 and y is greater than 0.
So we need the region-- let me
draw it this way-- the region
that is the first
quadrant in the xy-plane.
And it's not including
the x-axis or the y-axis.
So it's this full shaded region.
OK, that is the
region where it's
defined and differentiable.
If I was going to
write that precisely,
I would say something like, all
(x, y) with x greater than 0
and y greater than 0.
Right?
You need both.
So it's exactly the (x, y) pairs
with x positive and y positive,
and that's the region.
And now the question is, is
that region simply connected?
Well, the way we
think about simply
connectedness, from what
you've seen in class, is you
want to show that if you
take a closed curve that's
contained in the
region, that everything
on the interior of that closed
curve is also in the region.
And you notice that is in fact
true for this first quadrant.
Any closed curve I draw
that's in the region, all
the points on the
interior of the curve
are also in the region.
So this domain where it's
defined and differentiable
is simply connected.
So the first one, it
All right.
So that's part a.
Part b-- let me
rewrite that one so
we don't have to zoom
over to the other side--
this was i plus j divided by
the function square root of 1
minus x squared minus y squared.
Well, we already know that
the square root function
is defined as long as the
inside function is greater
than or equal to 0.
Because it's in the
denominator, we actually
need this function 1
minus x squared minus y
squared to be greater than 0.
And that's also where it's
going to be differentiable.
The differentiable and
the defined regions
are exactly the
same, and they're
both where 1 minus x
squared minus y squared
is greater than 0.
Right?
The function is only defined
as long as this quantity is
greater than 0, and
that's exactly where
it's differentiable as well.
And so what does
this correspond to?
Well, if you think
about it, this
is actually 1 is greater than
x squared plus y squared.
And what are the points
that look like this?
Well, the x- and y-points
that satisfy this inequality
are the x- and y-values that
are on the interior of the unit
circle.
So if I draw a picture of that.
Let me try and dot
the unit circle.
It's not containing
the boundary,
but it's all the points that
are on the interior of the unit
circle.
Every point here, when I
take the ordered pair (x, y)
and it's on the interior
of the unit circle,
it satisfies this inequality.
Those are the only
points that do that.
So this is the region
that has this vector
field both differentiable
and defined.
Right?
Now, is this region
simply connected?
It is, again for
the same reason.
Because if you take
any closed curve here,
and you look at the interior
of that closed curve,
every point on the interior
of that closed curve
is also in the region.
Right?
So it is also simply connected.
OK.
So we had two so far that
were simply connected.
They were
different-looking regions,
but ultimately they both
had any closed curve,
the interior of it was all
contained in the region
that we were interested in.
So now the third one
we have is somewhat
similar-looking to
part b, except that
what's in the square root
is a little different.
So now we can use
exactly the same logic
as what we did in part b.
And what we see is by
the exact same logic
that this vector field will
be defined and differentiable
as long as x squared plus y
squared minus 1 is positive.
Because that's where the
square root function is
differentiable, and
that's also where
1 divided by the square root
of this thing is defined.
So they correspond to
exactly the same regions.
And that is x squared plus
y squared greater than 1.
So if you think about that,
what we did previously
was we had x squared plus
y squared less than 1.
So obviously if
you want x squared
plus y squared greater than
1, we're taking all the (x, y)
pairs that are outside
the unit circle.
So again, we take
We don't include
the unit circle,
because that's where x squared
plus y squared equals 1.
And then we want all of the
values outside of that region.
So this extends off to infinity.
All of the values
outside of that region.
Now, is this region
simply connected?
It is not.
And the point is that while
you do have some curves,
that if I take a
closed curve, all
of the points on the
interior of that closed curve
are in the region, there are
some curves for which that's
not true.
For example, if
I take the circle
of radius-- what does that
look like-- 2, 1 and 1/2,
something like that?
If I look at all of the points
on the interior of this curve--
I'm going to try and shade
it without getting rid
of everything, so
you can see still
what's behind-- if I look
at all those points, notice
in particular, there
are a bunch of points--
for instance, this one
here, this one here,
and this one here-- all the
ones inside the unit circle,
are on the interior
of this curve,
but they're not in the region.
Right?
I'll shade it extra dark.
All the points that
are in here, that
are inside the unit
circle, are actually still
on the interior of this curve,
but they're not in the region.
And while there are some
curves for which everything
on the inside is in
the region, but there
are some curves for
which it's not true,
and that is what we know about
not-simply connectedness.
So we know this one is
not simply connected.
OK.
So now we have one left.
And the last one was i
plus j, times natural log
of x squared plus y squared.
So in this vector field,
what I'm really interested in
is the behavior of this function
natural log of x squared
plus y squared.
And the point I want to make
is that natural log is defined
as long as the input
value is positive,
and it is differentiable
everywhere it's defined.
And so this function will be
both defined and differentiable
as long as x squared plus y
squared is greater than 0.
So it's defined for
all of these values,
and natural log is
differentiable everywhere it's
defined.
So it's also differentiable
for all of these values.
And so we see that
this vector field
is defined and differentiable
everywhere except at one point.
And so let me draw--
this is a zooming
in of that it's
missing that point-- I
want to make it extra large.
But it's really only
missing one point.
And what point is that?
That point is the origin.
So everywhere except the origin.
Maybe I should make it
smaller, because maybe it
looks like it's
missing a whole circle.
It's just missing the point.
It's just missing the origin.
But every other
point on the xy-plane
is a place where
this vector field
is differentiable and defined.
Right?
So it's only missing
that one point,
but that still gives us the
fact that this region is not
simply connected.
And again, it's
exactly the same type
of logic as the
previous problem,
that I could draw curves, where
every point on the interior
is contained in the region.
But there are curves
that also fail.
Right?
If I draw a curve that contains
the origin, every point
on the interior of this
region except the origin,
is contained in the
domain of interest, right?
But because the interior of
the curve contains the origin,
I know that this region is,
in fact, not simply connected.
So if I look at all of R^2--
so if I look at all the (x,
y)-values except x
equals 0 and y equals 0--
except the origin-- I get
a region that's not simply
connected.
And this one is maybe
a little tricky,
so I'm going to say
it one more time.
OK?
So while there are
some curves that we
can see some portions
of this region
behave like simply connected
regions, when you're
around the origin, any curve
you take around the origin
is going to contain the
origin on its interior.
Right?
But the origin is not in
our domain of interest.
And therefore, there
are curves that we
can take that their interior
contains a point that's
not in the region.
And that's what it means
to be not simply connected.
OK?
So let me go back
to the beginning
and just remind you again
real quickly what we did here.
We had these four vector fields.
We wanted to do two
things with all of them.
We wanted to first find the
regions where they were defined
and differentiable, and then
determine if those regions were
simply connected.
And so we had two
examples where the regions
were simply connected.
And then I gave you two examples
where the regions were not
simply connected.
And so hopefully this
was informative for how
we can understand that vector
fields are not necessarily
always defined
everywhere, but also
to understand what this simply
connected region term actually
means.
And I guess that's
where I'll stop.